philippe berre dont je vous remercie
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france le collectif d'organisation
syndicale a appelé à la grève générale
aujourd'hui alors concrètement quelles
sont vos revendications
bonjour
les choses se sont empirées oui parce
qu'au faîte de l'historique des
sanitaires n'entendent pas raison
pourquoi à notre sens le 17 juillet nous
sommes en manifestations chaque samedi à
un meeting dans chaque commune de l'île
nous expliquons à la population il y a
une population en face qui est positive
à l'injection aériennes que l'on nous
présente comme un vaccin nous sommes
contre l'obligation vaccinale
absolument contre l'obligation vaccinale
nous sommes où la liberté de chacun de
choisir eux
j'étais rapide aux traitements qui
décide d'avoir avec son médecin la
relation intime il doit qu'avec son
médecin nous sommes contre la loi du 5
août nous estimons que tout a été fait
pour ainsi peu de résultats quand on
regarde de quasiment depuis le
gouvernement a changé pas mal d re
énormément d'erreurs et aujourd'hui
cette affaire de bouygues à 105
vaccinale n'est que le reflet de du
doigt des conduits de du blocage du
gouvernement du on ne comprend pas
exactement l'objectif précis du
gouvernement sinon de nous mettre que
dans une cache donc sa série pas
possible les libertés publiques sont en
danger et en termes sanitaires n'ont pu
dénoncer des maisons fondamentales qui
font là on n'avait jamais oublié
aujourd'hui nous payons les pots cassés
et pourtant vous êtes en première ligne
vous en tant que soignant vous êtes plus
exposées à certaines maladies là en
l'occurrence il s'agit du coc vide 19
pourquoi autant de réticences
c'était le cas l'an dernier appelé vous
étiez aussi au fond
et pourtant on nous appelait malgré le
fait que certains d'entre nous étaient
positifs donc ça c'est un art ou du
moins qui ne tient pas pourquoi
absolument nous ce n'est pas un argument
sérieux
l'argument qui tient ses deux dents plus
d'ailleurs que il faut savoir que son
équipe ne sont pas conformes à ce que la
firme d'audit mais ce ne sont pas les
soignants qui sera en capacité de
transmettre nous avons toutes les
maladies possibles
qui traînent dans un hôpital je ne sont
pas les soignants qu'il amène et ramène
donc cet argument là ça ne peut pas que
dire où
il y a effectivement certaines
obligations vaccinales qui existe avec
de vrais vaccins et nous nous estimons
dans par une revendication il faut
mettre sur la table la panoplie complète
il faut ouvrir et homologué d'autres
types de vaccins particulièrement les
martiens conventionnel ce qui va
arracher la population parce que je
rappelle que les vaccins qui sont en
cause et notamment aujourd'hui les deux
derniers puisqu'elle il ya deux autres
autorités quasiment éliminé la situation
que massimo l'état et réseau sur son des
vaccins
qui est on relève d'une nouvelle
technologie à base à un message et nous
avons passé avec les
c'est un argument que nous répétons que
nos vachon la population est clairement
opposé aujourd'hui à force d explication
avec vitalité et et à force de ne pas
être entendus voilà voilà ce que ça
donne aujourd'hui à partir du bilan
collectif effectivement deux
organisations syndicales mais pas
seulement il y à des associations
salle suivi les associations citoyennes
des organisations politiques qui s'y
mettent et aujourd'hui à partir de ce
matin d'ailleurs eu très tôt ce matin
lille est complètement bloquée alors
longtemps bien vous êtes déterminé à
poursuivre votre mouvement de grève est
ce que vous ne craignez pas quand même
un essoufflement voilà un petit peu de 2
c de ces mouvements là puisqu'on sait
que le ministère de la santé a quand
même annoncé que les deux tiers des
soignants qui étaient suspendus sont
retournés au travail après s'être
vacciner donc il y en a certains quand
même qu'ils n'hésitent pas à franchir le
pas
alors les chiffres du ministère a dit
moi je j'ai quelques doutes
pourquoi je vous dis ça premièrement il
est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
pression sur beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup
de contractuels et en plus le ministère
mélange des genres on parle beaucoup des
morts il ya eu au moins deux mois d'août
a aidé cette forme on parle très peu des
milliers de gens et notamment des
soignants qui ont été commis des donc
ces chiffres là il faudrait qu'on les
décortiquant peut savoir exactement le
vrai duel alors ceci étant dit il faut
que vous sachiez que c'est grâce aux
organisations syndicales
quelque part si ce moment là n'est pas
encore vraiment démarré parce que nous
servons de tampon mais derrière nous il
ya une population qui en a vraiment
marre et confirmation pourrait devancer
cette population elle attendait que ce
moment là et pour elle il faut passer à
la vitesse supérieure il ya imposé un
rapport de france parce que le
gouvernement lui
et nous sommes comme des vers d'une il
ya eu beaucoup de
stylistes us produit
vraiment
complètement
chez lequel guerre
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
bélair d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la cgt santé guadeloupe